[Music]
adopt a simple habit every single
morning i do a very simple thing i write
down five things that i want
that's it
when i start my day after i get up on
the alarm rings i make my bed i pull on
my exercise clothes i set an intention i
high-five myself in the mirror i then go
out into the kitchen i crack open my
high-five journal and then inside the
journal there are prompts that walk me
through the steps of visualizing and the
first prompt is dream with the lid off
set your spirit free write down five
things every morning that you want and
this is important because when you get
what you want out of your head
and you physically put them on a piece
of paper research shows that you're 42
more likely to achieve those goals
simply by writing them down that's
pretty cool
secondly your mind is paying attention
and when you take deliberate action and
you write down what you want you are
signaling to your brain
that you
deserve to have these things you are
signaling to your brain that you do want
those things you're not just going to
think about them these are things that
matter to you and that helps train your
mind to allow you to let the desires
flow through you because right now
you're not manifesting properly because
you're not even allowing yourself to
dream with the lid off so that's step
number one you're gonna start writing
down five things that you want every
single morning as a way to train your
mind to let you dream freely need
motivation you better watch a top 10
with believe nation hey it's evan
carmichael and i make these videos
because you are probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you get
that push by surrounding yourself with
the best so today let's learn from one
of the best mel robbins and my take on
her top 10 rules to success enjoy
rule number two high five your own
reflection we all know
that we need to love ourselves right
how do you do that um
i don't know
what is the action that you take yeah we
all know we're supposed to accept
ourselves
we all know we're supposed to
uh
have self-esteem and self-worth and
self-validation and self-confidence
how do you
build it
and you know the other thing is that we
also are looking outside ourselves
for confirmation validation affirmation
of those things
and so how do you relocate the source of
your self-confidence self-esteem
self-worth self-validation within
yourself so that you're in control of it
big idea right
so uh let me tell you the story about
how i discovered this because it was not
like a oh how do i have another high
five moment you know
i get fired from my talk show
and
i
uh am essentially fired from my dream
job i then start having speech after
speech after speech after speech cancel
then houghton mifflin cancels my
contract for my next book and asks for
me to return money that i've long spent
and why'd they cancel it because because
of pandemic they laid off there are two
reasons first of all they were they were
laying off 45 percent of the staff but
more importantly let me take
responsibility i was a year late on
delivering a man okay so let's be honest
i [__] up yet again yeah i ghosted my
publisher and they fired my ass um as
they should a long play to ghost your
publisher right
how about spend your money and then
ghost you
um but
i found myself again in this like
familiar place having
sort of
echoes back to a decade ago of oh my god
are we in financial free fall again like
is this ride over
kids come home you did like 100 speeches
in a year or prior to that or prior to
the show yep and then took a pay cut to
do the show yep
and look i i've been saving money i've
been very smart about about money now
that i've made it we've paid back all of
our debt something we're both really
really proud of
um and
at the same time when it's a fan in your
life your old things will get triggered
and what got triggered for me is i'm
about to lose it all again right
meanwhile just like everybody else on
the planet your kids come home and it's
both a blessing and a horror show to
have your children in a state of
distress as the world is in distress and
i just started to feel overwhelmed
and there was this one morning
where um
i
walked into the bathroom
and i was standing in my underwear
brushing my teeth in front of the mirror
and i looked up at the mirror and my
first thought was
uh
i
noticed that my jowls were starting to
look like saddle bags on a pack horse at
the grand canyon
and uh i had like these crazy lines by
my eyes and my neck was really like kind
of saggy and one boob was hanging lower
than the other and my gray hair was
coming in and i and as soon as i started
kind of critiquing my
thoughts or my looks and appearance then
my mind rich started going
i didn't get that email back to that
person and i got that presentation i
need to do and my god did that speech
just cancel again what the [__] am i
going to do i look down and the dog
needs to be walked and then i think i
got a zoom call in nine minutes like i
got to get my
and before i knew it my whole mood was
low i felt overwhelmed i had taken
myself down mentally
i just wanted somebody to walk in and be
like mal you it's gonna be okay like you
got this girl like it's lift your head
up you can handle this
i don't know what came over me rich
this is
pathetic
but standing there in my underwear
in front of my bathroom sink
i raise my hand
and high five my reflection
and i cracked a smile because it's so
corny
i even thought of that guy stuart smiley
from the snl skips remember that i'm
nice i'm kind people like me
went on with my day
that was it
snapped a photo though no not that one
oh not that one
not the first time and then
i kept doing it i did it probably for
a week or two
and here's the weird thing about it i
started when i woke up after doing this
high five-year-old reflection in the
mirror thing
i actually started to feel like i was
looking forward to it
and here's why you know i've spent a
lifetime just like you standing in front
of the mirror and what i realize now is
that when i'm standing in front of a
mirror i'm either critiquing
or picking myself apart
or i'm ignoring myself
and when you start to high-five your own
reflection
it starts to build a partnership
within you with yourself
when you walk into the bathroom and you
see your reflection and you've been
greeting it it's like seeing another
person
it's the strangest thing you start to
realize how often you ignore or destroy
yourself when you see yourself or beat
yourself up
and here's what's also crazy
you have a lifetime and this is where
the science gets wacky and i'm going to
hit you with so much science because
this stuff is so cool
you have a lifetime positive association
with high-fiving other people
sure as a runner as a racer you have
gotten so many high fives rich what does
a high five say to you when somebody
gives you one
you feel seen you feel appreciated you
feel energized by it and it's a it's an
exchange of energy it's not the same and
you talk about this in the book it's not
the same as like self-talk because
there's a participation involved in it
there's like a communion yes back to it
yeah and you know if you think about it
you're so good
at celebrating seeing and cheering for
other people in your life you plan
birthday parties you reach out to people
when you're worried about them you help
out colleagues you cheer for your
favorite sports teams you high-five
people like rich as they're running
races past you you buy people's
merchandise you do all kinds of stuff
for other people
but nobody's taught you how to do it for
yourself
in fact the reason why it feels
weird to high-five your own reflection
is because you've been taught to do the
opposite rule number three find a mantra
you believe in the reason why those
positive i love myself i'm happy with
who i am i accept myself the reason why
those mantras don't work in the
beginning
is because
your brain rejects it
you've spent a lifetime trashing your
body trashing yourself telling yourself
you're stupid telling yourself that
you're not good enough telling yourself
that nothing's ever going to work out
for you there is no way that you're
going to be able to stand in front of a
mirror everybody look yourself in the
eye and say today's the day that i'm
going to forget all that stuff and i'm
just going to accept myself
and the reason why it's not going to
work is because all day long you then
continue to beat yourself up
and so what does work well i'm going to
read from chapter seven
of my new york times bestselling book
the high five habit the place where we
left off for those of you is page 91
where we were talking about training
your mind
to
change
the way that it views the world
intentionally training your mind to help
you
and this is an important thing to learn
how to do
because if your mind is going to accept
new ways of thinking and new beliefs
about you you must also train your mind
to start to
see the world differently and so you can
do the exercises that i'm teaching you
in conjunction with what i'm about to
teach you about mantras so
mistake number one when it comes to you
trying to become a more positive person
and when you are trying to change the
way that you talk to yourself
is you pick a mantra
that you do not at your core believe
okay
you pick something that is the
antithesis of how you actually believe
it yourself and so the mistake number
one that you're making when it comes to
mantras is that you're picking a mantra
that is so
far away from where you are that your
mind immediately rejects it so that's
mistake number one
mistake number two
is that you pick a mantra
that is simply just you repeating a
statement
that is the exact opposite of how you
speak to yourself and how you treat
yourself all day long and so you know
let me just talk about this on a common
sense standpoint
let's say
that you really want to become healthier
okay
how many of you want to become healthier
right
and you know all the things you need to
do how many of you want to become
healthier and you know the specific
actions you need to take in order to
become healthier
right
of course you know what to do you know
that you could eat
better food
you know that you could get more sleep
you know that you could move your body a
little bit more you know that you could
drink more water you know that you could
lay off the booze and the fatty starchy
foods all those little actions would add
up to a much healthier you are you with
me
yes of course you're with me okay so
knowing what to do is the easy part
knowing kind of what you want that's the
easy part
the problem
with sticking to those changes
is that your own
negative self-talk
trashes you all day long
and the negative self-talk
i'm so fat
oh there i go again
i said i wouldn't have dessert but i did
oh i said i wouldn't drink tonight and i
just did oh i said i was gonna go
gluten-free and i didn't oh i'm sad so
i'm gonna do this oh i don't feel
like going for a walk
all of that negative thinking and
talking
it makes you feel less motivated
and less worthy of the change that you
want
and so if you wake up every day and you
have a dream and a goal of becoming
healthier and you know that today you're
going to move your body and today you're
going to drink more water and today
you're going to cut out the gluten and
today you're going to
uh
do whatever you're gonna you're gonna uh
donate the clothes that don't fit so you
stop trashing yourself all things that
make you feel better right
if you stand in front of the mirror and
you say
i love you and i accept you exactly how
you are
i love you and you deserve to be you
know like and and and i i love myself
and i i i'm gonna be healthy i'm gonna
be the best me i can be
and then the next thing you do is you go
into the kitchen
and you glug glug glug glug pour a ton
of cream into your coffee
your mind is immediately going to go why
did you just do that oh my god here i go
i'm one minute into this
and your own negative self-talk just
overrode what you said in the mirror
that mantra that i love myself and i
accept myself by the time you got into
the kitchen you have already trashed
yourself
the pouring the cream in the coffee
is an example that you don't love
yourself you're not sticking to your
word and now your motivation goes boo
to change right
this is why most mantras are complete
[__] you're picking something you
don't believe
so what will work
because the truth is
research says
that
having a positive attitude
having an optimistic attitude
being kind to yourself
is the secret to motivation and
inspiration
when you treat yourself with respect
when you cheer yourself forward when you
forgive yourself when you screw up you
are going to feel more worthy and you're
going to feel more encouraged and you're
going to feel more likely
to pick yourself back up
dump the coffee with the cream out make
the coffee with the plant-based thing
that you said you would drink shrug your
shoulders laugh that you just
instinctively poured the cream in and
then
there you go
take a sip of your coffee
so we know that positive talk helps we
know that kindness helps when it comes
to motivation
the problem is you're picking a mantra
that is so high in the sky
and it's making you feel far away from
what you want
and so what will work i'll tell you what
works and then i'm going to read to you
from the high five habit
mantras only work
number one
if you believe them
i'm going to say that again mantras only
work if you believe them
so if you're somebody that has struggled
with self-acceptance
for a very long time
it will not work for you to stand in
front of the mirror when you feel broken
and you're at the beginning of your
journey of taking control of your life
it will not work for you to stand in
front of the mirror and to say
i love and accept myself
because as you stand in front of the
mirror and say that your brain is going
to be like no you don't did you see how
you treated yourself yesterday you do
not opens accept yourself i know i'm a
ventriloquist now i'm your brain
and then that truth
that your actions don't align with what
you're saying
plummets your motivation and your desire
to change
so what you have to do is pick a mantra
that you actually believe rule number
four build a positive mindset number one
the secret to an optimistic mindset you
got to be maniacal about your intake
negativity in here means negativity in
your body gets stored here and
negativity comes out here
it becomes this loop of negativity
and so in order to build a positive
mindset i want you to be maniacal about
positive input that means
really watch your news intake
do not be watching it every day get the
facts
get what you need to know from a trusted
measured
calm factual source
and then turn that [__] off okay that's
number one number two edit your social
media
anything on your social media feeds
should be
helping you be more resilient
more optimistic
more
positive
anything
that you're following that triggers you
that is negative that rubs you the wrong
way you know one of the things that i've
noticed
i have some favorite celebrities that i
have
followed for a while because i think
they're funny or i love um
just kind of their sense of humor
but there are so many people that i have
muted right now because i think that
what they're doing online is so freaking
out of whack
seeing people give us advice about
quarantining from the back of their
estates and mansions telling us to
donate when they're not saying they're
donating
seeing this kind of tone-deaf
celebrity thing going on i'm normally
not a negative person about that but i
have muted muted muted so many accounts
because it's not doing anything for me
and you got to be selfish right now you
have got to edit your social media feeds
so that your social media feeds are
helping you build an optimistic and
positive mindset and so every day the
second i see summit mute mute mute mute
unfollow unfollow unfollow because
negativity in means negativity gets
stored here it's negativity goes out
there from you you want to put
positivity optimism tools strategies
things that keep you laughing keep
things that keep you giving you things
that you can use right now the second
you start getting overloaded with corona
stuff mute that stuff edit edit edit
your social media based on what you need
that's number one maniacal about your
intake
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there
rule number five visualize the steps to
success
you must
visualize the steps that lead you
to the thing that you want
not the end goal
this is a major mistake that people make
they manifest
improperly because all they do is focus
on the end goal if you've ever made a
vision board think about what you put on
the vision board you put up just the
beach house or the million dollars in
the bank are you crossing the finish
line are you launching that business or
you having the body that you want are
you a driving the maserati whatever it
is the end goal is what you put up on a
vision board that is not what you're
going to do when you manifest if you
start focusing on crossing the finish
line of the marathon that is a one-way
ticket to being unmotivated and
completely discouraged in fact research
shows that if all you do is focus on the
thing that you want and you just focus
on that vision of you and your bikini
body or you with the love of your life
on your arms or you at the
oscars winning that award or the grammys
what happens is because you've only
focused on the end goal
you start to feel really unmotivated and
discouraged because you're nowhere near
it
that's where manifesting comes in
because we're not going to focus on the
end goal
you got to pick something that you want
in order to get started but manifesting
isn't about the end
it's about the bridge
it's about going from where you are here
to where you want to go
imagine that there is a bridge
that connects where you are right here
with what you dream about doing
now that dream could be to be a grammy
award-winning
singer-songwriter that dream might be to
have a family of your own that dream
might be to have a beach house or a ski
house or to take a trip to fiji that
dream can be whatever the hell you want
it to be
but when it comes to manifesting once
you've given yourself permission to
dream with the lid off and really want
what you want to feel the pull of that
thing now we got to talk about the path
that connects where you are with where
you want to go
and this is all about visualizing the
little steps there's a lot of research
that proves why visualizing the steps
is
the most important thing that you could
do
there was a study done at ucla for
example
where they were researching
manifestation and the power of
visualization and they broke students
into two groups and they had group a
we're going to call these the vision
board group they had group a
close their eyes visualize in their mind
and feel in their body
themselves taking the test
and then walking up
to a board where the tests
scores were posted
and finding their name and seeing an
a-plus
that's what group a the vision board
group were told to do
to visualize themselves achieving what
they wanted
group b
we're going to call these the hard
workers these students were coached in
this research project to close their
eyes and to visualize going back to
their dorm room
sitting down at the desk
and studying
and staying up late
and putting in the work studying and
preparing for the tests
now let me ask you a question which
group do you think did better on the
actual test
was it group a the vision board group
who were taught to visualize and picture
themselves walking up to a board and
seeing the a plus
or was it group b
the hard work group
the group that was taught to close their
eyes and visualize and seeing themselves
doing the work to study for the test
well if you answered group a you're
wrong
if you answered group b
you got the correct answer
the reason why group b
the students who visualize studying for
the test got better test scores is
because when you visualize yourself
doing the work
visualizing it leads you to doing the
work
and it's only through actions that you
will get the result that you want
preparing your mind and visualizing
yourself doing it
lowers your resistance and leads to you
taking the action that's why manifesting
works you know the same is true in
sports there's all kinds of research in
sports psychology in fact our olympic
athletes for the u.s olympic team they
hire sports psychologists to train our
top olympic athletes particularly after
they've been injured
in visualizing themselves competing
when you coach an athlete to mentally
rehearse every single detail about going
through the competition you are training
the mind body and spirit to show up and
dominate this is particularly true for
athletes after they've been injured and
they're stepping back into competition
if you've been injured in competition
you're naturally going to feel anxious
you're naturally going to be nervous
your brain and nervous system circuitry
is now programmed with the intensity
from that injury the memory from the
injury so of course it's natural to
bring that in to your
pre-competition
feelings about it right
so manifestation properly remember what
it is manifesting is preparing your mind
body and spirit to do the work it's
aligning your mind body and spirit with
what you want it removes the obstacles
that would normally stop you which then
prepares and motivates you to take the
actions to succeed so in the case of
athletes who visualize themselves and
see themselves doing all the steps over
and over they're removing the nerves
they're removing all the programming
related to the injury they are preparing
their mind body and spirit to go in and
frickin dominate and so are you rule
number six train your mind and one of
the things that will help you
to do the work to create the things that
you want in your life
is it will help you if you train your
mind
to start spotting
evidence
as you're doing the work as you're going
through your day it will help you if you
train your mind to start scanning the
world and spotting evidence
that yes indeed
the world is sending you positive
signals that things are going to work
out now why is it important to train
your mind to help you get what you want
well the reason why is because
if you get into a negative mindset if
you start thinking
this business is never going to work why
even bother i'm never gonna meet anybody
it's nothing but losers out there look
at all these idiots on hinge why the
hell should i keep doing this if you
allow your mind to start to rest in a
pessimistic
negative protective scared and doubtful
stance
your mind will continue to show you
reasons why there's nobody on hinge
worth talking to your mind will continue
to show you all the reasons why you will
never make it in business your mind will
continue to show you all the reasons why
you're never going to lose that weight
and be able to tuck in your shirt as my
friend corinne crabtree always talks
about that transformational moment and
when your mind goes negative your mind
starts to scan the world and will show
you more reasons to stop
and the power of training your mind to
spot positive signs is very simple
the power is that your mind will start
to show you reasons to keep going
your mind will help you take the step
your mind will encourage you to feel
optimistic to feel empowered just like
you woke up today on a tuesday and it
was february 22nd
2022 and those numbers are lining up and
that makes you in your heart and soul go
whoa
something cool could happen today like
that only happens like once in my
lifetime those numbers are going to line
up like that today
is a really cool day let's go do
something with this
you could create that kind of attitude
every single freaking day of your life
you could
if you train your mind and if you start
taking action and training your mind is
the key piece that we're going to talk
about
so for those of you that have read the
high five habit one of the things that i
talk about a lot is every single day
find a naturally occurring heart-shaped
object in the world it could be a stone
it could be a leaf it could be a cloud
it could be a shape in your coffee hey
chris if we've got anything around here
that looks like a heart hand it to me
and the reason why i love telling you to
start playing a game with yourself where
you start your day going mind brain show
me some heart oh what is this come here
dog treat oh my god it's a dog treat
look at this guys
what shape is that
that right there is a heart
there we go
check that out
if you say
brain
mind show me a heart today guess what's
gonna happen that damn dog biscuit
it's gonna show it's gonna you're gonna
be like there's a heart you're gonna
look out at the sky and you're gonna see
a heart shape oh right there in the
mountains there's a heart shape in the
mountains in southern vermont you're
gonna see it in the clouds what you're
doing when you tell your mind what's
important to you is you're telling your
mind and the filter in your brain to
change in real time and allow into your
consciousness
what's important to you and if you want
to see hearts by god those damn dog
treats are going to start looking like
hearts everybody that's how you train
your mind it's freaking incredible and
if you want to see evidence of this
follow me on social media if you follow
me mel robbins on social media you will
see every day i am reposting your
stories of finding heart shapes around
the world now why is this important well
it's important because it's a simple way
to prove to you that your mind changes
in real time that if you get serious
about becoming more positive and
optimistic and encouraging of yourself
if you get serious about saying [__]
this i don't wanna see all the reasons
why i'm unhappy i don't wanna see
uh everybody else in the world that's
launched a business or that's lost
weight and is healthy or that has a
really good uh marriage or relationship
and i don't want to see that and and and
have my mind process it as evidence that
it's never going to happen for me
i want my mind to reprogram itself and
see other people's businesses and see
other people getting healthy and see
other people in relationships and i want
my mind to say
yeah
if they can do it i can do it that's
evidence if that person can get healthy
so can i if that person can find
somebody unhinge so can i if that person
can reconcile with their child so can i
other people can become evidence that
you can have it too right now your mind
is so [__] up from your past that when
you see what other people have and you
don't have it you can't actually
translate it through a negative mind and
and see that that's evidence that you're
gonna win you see it like oh somebody
already stole what i wanted that sucks
and so what i want to start to open your
mind to is that you have the power to
train your mind
to filter the world differently just
like you woke up and you saw the date
today 2 22 22 and your brain saw that
was like whoa
this is a once in a lifetime day
everybody
you are never going to have another day
that lines up like this
ever what are you going to do with this
day your mind already interpreted this
as wow
something cool could happen
and if you tell yourself something
amazing is going to happen today
will because you're gonna be looking for
it i swear to god something will
something will if you wanna see the good
all around you you gotta tell your mind
you wanna see the good and this just
isn't a bunch of horse everybody this
isn't toxic positivity there is a filter
in your brain called the reticular
activating system
the reticular activating system i call
it the ras i like to think about it like
a giant hair net on your head and this
ras sits over your brain i'm probably
getting this wrong i'm not a
neuroscientist i could give a sh about
getting it right i just need you to know
the basics here so that you can apply it
to your life okay you don't need a phd
to use the science that super smart
people have been working really hard on
in order to apply it to your life
that's what i'm here for in your life
i'm here to translate this stuff into
simple believable and actionable things
that you can do
to take all this super cool stuff that
people are researching and apply it to
your normal person's everyday life to
help you
change from the inside out and one of
the coolest things that you have at your
disposal is you have a whole system in
your body that you can
train and change
and one of those things that you can
that is impacted by that real that word
you're hearing a lot of neuroplasticity
that just means that things are able to
twist and bend and change and you're
able to learn new things for as long as
you're alive
as long as you're breathing everybody
you got a chance to change the way that
you think as long as you are breathing
you got a chance to change from the
inside out how you experience your life
as long as you are still here watching
me people you got a chance to create a
new experience in your life and one of
the things that helps a lot is
understanding that right now all of the
bull from your past has jammed the
filter in your mind body and spirit the
reticular activating system
and it is clouding your ability to look
at the world around you and see
hearts remember this dog treat hearts
look at that there's a heart right there
rule number seven boost your mood do
tiny things every day that boost your
mood okay
so we're going to build your mood muscle
if you can move your body
because negativity gets stored here and
moving your body we know based on the
research simply moving your body for 10
or 20 minutes a day will release
chemicals in your mind
that help you boost your mood the second
thing that will boost your mood is i
want you to make a tiny promise to
yourself every day just one thing that
makes you feel more positive is it
getting up on time
is it eating something healthy
is it only having one glass of wine or
reaching for a mock tail i want you to
put one tiny promise into place put it
into the
um comments right now what's one tiny
promise that you can make to yourself
that you're going to do every day it
might just be that you're going to wake
up every day take a deep breath remind
yourself that you're healthy and that's
going to be the tiny promise i want you
to do one tiny promise every day because
keeping a promise
to yourself will boost your mood and
make you feel more in control another
way to build your mood muscle is
have a zero tolerance policy for your
own negative thoughts
right now as you edit social media and
edit your news take and edit your
negativity coming in from the outside
world
do not tolerate negativity from the
inside world i woke up this morning i
looked in the mirror
i looked at the gray hairs that are
coming in particularly like right up
here
and i started to go negative i started
to feel dreary and i went mel cut this
out you got to fight to stay positive
gal because we are in this for another
couple months and do not succumb to
despair do not start thinking negative
stuff when you have negativity
internally you got to have a zero
tolerance policy for that
it's one thing to feel what you need to
feel
so that you can move through it it's
another thing to let negativity dwell up
here and start ruminating fi the five
second rule is genius for this count
backwards the second that negative 54321
not listening to it no i am redirecting
my thoughts that's right i am looking
for the things i can control i am
keeping a positive attitude by focusing
on things that i can control right now
today rule number eight do the work this
one is like really important
you need to do the work okay
you got to do the work
because it's only through your actions
that you will accomplish what you want
let's say uh that you've always wanted
to climb a particular mountain okay
there's a mountain called haystack it's
not even that tall so i should probably
pick a bigger one but let's just call it
haystack mountain you've always wanted
to climb haystack mountain you pull up
to haystack mountain
and you get out of the car you park at
the you know national forest parking lot
and you make the mistake of looking up
at the mountain which is the end goal
right
and you notice it's up in the clouds
and then you start to think oh my god
that's a really far way away
you know i don't really know how i feel
about doing this anymore because that
looks like it's going to take a really
long time and then all of a sudden it
starts to rain and you go i don't think
i want to do this because i don't think
i feel like doing this and next thing
you know you are back in the car driving
back down the road to that little diner
that you saw and instead of climbing the
mountain that you've always dreamt of
climbing you've now
come up with an excuse
and you have abandoned ship you now have
literally become your own obstacle you
talked yourself out of it you started to
doubt yourself you told yourself you
weren't ready and that you didn't feel
like it
you pull the rip cord you're out of
there in order to have what you want in
life
you must stop staring at the top of that
mountain
you must stop creating excuses for why
you can't or don't feel like it and you
must put your head down
and look at the first step in front of
you
and then you must take the action and
start walking toward what you want and
it'll be a hell of a lot easier for you
to do that if you have also
been putting in the time every day
consistently to not only see yourself
walking up that trail step by step but
that you have felt yourself pushing
through the resistance the fear the
obstacles the
the excuses that are stopping you now
and feel proud in every fiber of your
being as you push through those
obstacles and see yourself and feel
yourself doing the work that's how you
manifest properly
and if you do that before you pull into
the
national park parking lot
if you look up at that mountain and you
see clouds and it starts raining it
won't matter because you've already
rehearsed this moment in your mind body
and spirit
and you my friend will start walking up
that trail
and you're gonna be proud
that's how you use manifesting to get
what you want that's how you leverage
all the science and research to train
and prepare your mind body and spirit to
help you
get what you want and that's how you
hack the motivation and inspiration that
you need to take the actions that get
you everything that you want and deserve
in life rule number nine learn to cheer
for yourself the other stuff that's
super cool about this is that you know
we've all bought into this lie that
somehow beating yourself up and tough
love and being hard on yourself is
motivating
wrong
all the research shows that it is
demotivating if you're somebody that's
stuck if you're somebody that has
regrets if you're somebody that is tired
of where you are if you feel like you
know you just why can't i change
beating yourself up is making it worse
you have to learn how to cheer for
yourself
where you are
because if you're not you will never
find the motivation to change so they
did this study with kids where they
broke kids into three different groups
okay
and they gave the kids very challenging
problems and they wanted to know what
was going to be
the thing that researchers could do to
motivate and inspire kids to work
through a challenging problem and
what is going to be the most effective
thing that we could do to give somebody
that boost that you need to really face
something that's hard so group number
one got the old fixed mindset praise
where it's like hey you're super smart
rich hey rich you're really good looking
in those glasses and i bet they help you
make you focus on this problem keep
going buddy
the second group got the fixed mindset
praise which is hey rich you're really
really working hard rich that
perseverance is amazing keep going the
third group
they got a simple high five
no words
just a high five
the group with the simple high five
outperformed
the other two group and then some
that's why
why i'll tell you why a high five is
fulfilling
your fundamental emotional needs it's
not about the problem when you high-five
somebody including yourself you are
affirming that somebody exists
you are saying i see you
and you're celebrating with them you
know how those things go viral uh all
year long of of uh teachers standing
outside their classroom doing individual
handshakes with kids it's the same thing
every one of those kids is being seen as
an individual and celebrated and rule
number 10 the last one before some very
special bonus clips is reclaim your mind
body and spirit your past has completely
[__] up the reticular activity system
the reason why you doubt yourself the
reason why you think nothing works out
for you the reason why you're seeking
validation from everybody else is
because your life trained you to do that
and i'm here to tell you you can wake
the hell up
and you can realize
that from this moment forward you
have the ability using simple and
believable tools
to reclaim
your mind body and spirit to retrain it
and to use it to help you
feel the way that you want to feel to
experience life the way that you want to
experience life and to build a sense of
momentum
as you go through your day and you start
to see
all kinds of stuff around you as
evidence that you can have it to i'll
give you a simple example so as many of
you know for a very long time i've
always wanted to launch a podcast i got
my start in the media business back in
by having a local radio show in boston
massachusetts on a talk radio station on
saturday mornings that's what i did i
made 25 an hour i hosted a show for two
hours a live call-in show where we
talked about what was going on in the
world it was an advice show i absolutely
loved it and from there uh that show
grew it then uh became a sunday night
show in atlanta and then i got a five
day a week show in orlando so you're
looking at a woman who got her start in
the media business doing local radio i
paid for our kids braces by reading
invisalign ads for the local dentist so
i have been in sort of the radio or
podcast business
since 2007 since before podcasts and
then my life took detours like it did i
have not been in radio since god 2011
maybe so long time 10 years and i've
been thinking about launching a podcast
for five years everybody five years
and every time i would think about it
my mind would look around and
my mind my reticular activity system the
filter in my brain was clogged with all
kinds of crap
and when i looked around and i saw all
these people launching podcasts
that
fact of seeing it would filter through
my mind and my mind would say
there's no room for you you're too late
you're not going to be as good as those
other people
so my
mind was looking
at the outside world
and the fact that everybody and their
mother was launching a podcast five
years ago and they still are today
and it would pass through the filter in
my brain
and my brain would say to me mel you're
you might as well just stop thinking
about it because you're too late woman
how many of you do that to yourself that
you see other people having what you
want and the way that that
fact that somebody else has gotten
healthier somebody else has made a
million dollars or somebody else has
launched a business online or somebody
else has
found somebody after divorce and is
happier than ever and you see that and
you immediately assume i'm
like it's never going to happen for me
instead of having your brain go
whoa
look at that
look at all these people out there doing
this if they can do it you can do it too
mel look at that you got all these
people that can give you advice you got
all these people that are lights on the
path that you want to walk down how cool
is that you got all kinds of information
all kinds of help all kinds of evidence
that's positive
well the reason why my mind didn't see
it as positive is the same reason why
your mind does not see everybody else's
business and everybody else's health
journey and everybody else's bank
account and everybody else's fancy
vacations or when you walk into a bar
and all your girlfriends get hit on
instead of you
your mind
does not see all of that as evidence
that it's going to eventually work out
for you because your mind is clogged
with all kinds of crap from your past
and i'm here to tell you
when you wake up and realize
that you could train your brain to wake
up every day and go holy sh today's
going to be a magical day today is going
to be that 2 22 22 day where you
immediately see this you know this is
the one day of your life where this is
going to be the day come on in jesse
jesse's here
hey yolo
yolo come on in you could you could
literally train your mind
to wake up every day and go damn it i'm
going to see a heart today and i'm going
to see evidence today that she's working
out for me and when my mind starts to
see
that this is going to work out for me
i'm going to feel more empowered i'm
going to feel more inspired and i'm
going to keep going because the bottom
line is everybody your positive mindset
helps you with momentum repetition and
discipline
your positive mindset helps you
by encouraging you to take the action
because as you know
because you hang out with me mel robbins
thinking about changing your life is not
going to change your life
the only thing that changes your life is
action
you want something different you gotta
do something different
but a
filter in your brain that filters the
world in a positive way in an
encouraging way a filter in your brain
that acts more like that annoying friend
you know that annoying friend who's
always trying to to build you up and i
say annoying because when you're
committed to being like it's never
working out for me i'm never gonna meet
anybody i'm never going to lose the
weight and your friend's like oh
are you kidding you know how amazing you
are you're like off don't tell me i'm
amazing i want to feel terrible
so when you start to change your brain
when you start to really go to work on
this filter
you're going to turn your own mind from
a critic
and somebody who's nasty
into that friend that's really cheering
you on see see this is going to work out
for you see you should keep going see
this is really good for you to do and
that's why it's important
it's really hard to take action
when you have a mindset
it's really hard
to find what's called the activation
energy the force to push yourself
through the resistance and the fear
if you are committed to believing
that it's not
worth doing anyway
and so
action is critical
action is where the five second rule
comes in
but if you want to supersize this and
step on the accelerator you must start
to train your mind
and one way you can start to do this is
to look for hearts every day that's one
chapter in the book we haven't read yet
see this is a dog treat that was shaped
like a heart i asked chris he scanned
the room boom that's how this works
the other way
that you can start to train your mind is
to learn about the filter in your brain
to learn about the fact that this filter
in your mind
has the ability to change in real time
what you see
first of all stop talking about passion
stop talking about launching a business
okay
when you think about it too big
it will paralyze you
if you're lucky and you're in a position
where
your bills are getting paid
and you have the luxury of being able to
try to think about what you want to do
in this next chapter
here's where i want you to start
i want you to start with what energizes
you now how ironic is that given that
i'm speaking at the energetic women's
conference here in indianapolis today
why am i saying energizes you and what
do i talk what am i talking about when i
say energize
when i say energizes you
i'm asking you what is it that you're
curious about
what is it that you feel so
expanded you feel energized you feel
kind of excited whenever you're doing it
you're in a phase when you're just
trying to figure out what's your next
move
of just paying attention to your
curiosity
paying attention to the things that
interest you the truth is
passion is just energy
if you're passionate about something it
means you're energized when you do it so
let's reverse engineer this and let's
just
ask yourself a simple question
what are you curious about what
energizes you and if you allow yourself
to explore things that energize you you
my friend will start to
find the clues about what it is that you
should and could be doing because all
the research says that if you're doing
something that you like
if you're doing something that you're
curious about you're not only going to
enjoy it you're going to be really good
at it because if you like doing it
you'll spend more time doing it which
means you're going to get better at it
the reason why it's so important to
start with a friend cleanse and i'm sure
a lot of you how many of you heard that
you thought oh my god getting rid of
people oh boy oh boy i'm gonna cleanse
these friends
yes and no
a friend cleanse is critical because the
single most influential thing around you
are the people that you hang out with
and if you have relationships
that are toxic if you have relationships
that cause guilt if you have
relationships that are creating drama in
your life if you have relationships that
are not equitable guess what
that's creating the overwhelm that's
creating unhappiness that's
keeping you doubting yourself if you
have friends that um have bad habits
guess what that's making it really
really hard for you to change your
habits for the good it comes back to the
core message that i always have for you
no matter what's happening around or to
you you hold the power
because you always have the power to
have an honest conversation you always
have the power to discuss how things are
impacting you you always have the power
to make requests and you certainly have
the power to draw boundaries and you
also have the power by the way if the
culture gets worse and worse or you just
are tired of it because it's not
changing to go find a different job
the power is always in you and i think
that's something that's so important to
constantly remind yourself i get that i
don't like where i am but what could i
do to change it
how can i change how i think about this
and i'm telling you right now you know
this the second you start changing how
you think about a situation the
situation changes the second you start
changing how you think about what your
options are you start to see them the
second you stop thinking that you're
stuck or that you're a victim and you
start thinking about how you solve
something you start to see solutions and
so the answer is always in you if you
look at
human development we're the only species
that literally can't survive without
another human being taking care of you
and so we are biologically
hard-wired to bond with other people and
that is the ver from the very beginning
of when you come out
bonding with somebody else and making
sure they pay attention to you is your
survival imperative so you are born
needing somebody else and i think what
ends up happening is there's never that
kind of clean
break or pass off between needing your
parents to take care of you needing your
friends approval to fit in to truly
having ownership over giving yourself
what you didn't get giving yourself what
you needed and that's the piece that
i've been doing a lot of during the the
great pause is slowing down because so
much of my busyness
was fueled by uh you know praise me love
me am i doing enough
you know please tell me i'm doing okay
okay i can breathe now i'm okay now
and when i slow down and maybe it's a
function of the anxiety that's when
things get scary because that's when
you've really got to be with yourself
you have this behavior pattern where you
snap you have this behavior pattern
where you yell and you get upset and you
make people wrong and you don't mean to
if you
are somebody who's ever said to yourself
i wish i could stop yelling or i wish i
i i i i could just snap i could stop
snapping
this video is absolutely unbelievable
okay and the reason why is i explain
this research that was so
mind-blowing for me
it's called ghosts in the nursery
a lot of the patterns that you have
that you don't have control over
are patterns from your childhood
and they are there because when you were
a kid
you experienced people in your life that
were tense
did you ever have a parent that was a
yeller
did you ever have a teacher that was a
yeller or a coach that was a yeller and
secretly in your little kid body
whenever your mom or dad would yell or
your coach would yell or your teacher
would yell or your grandmother or
grandfather would yell you would feel
tense right
you would feel nervous you would feel on
edge of course that's how we all feel
right well here's the reason why
you might have an issue like i used to
have an issue where i would yell at my
kids and then i'd feel terrible about it
i'd snap at my husband and then i'd feel
terrible about it psychologist and then
i would say to myself i'm not doing that
again i'm not doing that again but i
wouldn't have the ability to end it
psychologists call this ghost in the
nursery
it means that any situation where you
start to feel
tense or you start to feel stressed out
guess what happens your body remembers
what it was like when you were little to
feel tense and stressed out and what
were the adults doing around you when
you felt that way
they were snapping
they were yelling and now here you are
repeating the pattern
and you don't know why and you feel
guilty
and i'm explaining this to you because
it wasn't until i thought holy cow like
i know i don't want to snap at my
husband i know i don't want to take my
anger from work out on my family why
can't i stop this
that's the reason why it's because it's
a pattern that you remember from being a
kid that the adults around you were
snapping or yelling or being mean
any time and when they were you felt
tense and stressed out so now that
you're an adult when you're tense and
stressed out you repeat the behavior
that you witnessed crazy right so how do
you stop it well the first step to
stopping anything is to actually
understand what you're dealing with
now that you know you're dealing with a
pattern
now all you need to do is basically say
okay i'm going to put a practice in
place that's going to interrupt this
pattern what's the practice well a
really good one is
um
before you walk in the house at the end
of the day if you're stressed out take
five
take five deep breaths
like reset your mood reset your energy
before you walk in the house and you'll
be surprised by how much nicer you are
to the people around you
another thing that um
that uh
you can do and this one's not so fun
is you can train your
partner your kids your roommates your
family that if you're trying to get a
hold of how you bring stress home you
can train them to say to you hey don't
take your work stress out on me
when somebody that you care about says
that to you it's a humbling experience
and the person that says it the most in
my life is my son oakley your uh the
youngsters seem to love to cross-check
the adults so be careful with taking
that advice i know
that in this next chapter that i
consciously create i want to have more
fun
i wanna i really wanna love the process
yeah i don't want to make it so hard on
myself and be gripping everything so
tight and it's really easy for me to see
it in other people because i know what
it feels like in here
i'm working hard to break the patterns
that still hold me back and the big one
that holds me back is um bulldozing
that's the it's it's it's literally when
i start to feel
any level of tension this is
particularly true in my marriage
um i'm married to a saint thank god
chris robbins meditates every morning
it's the only reason why we've lasted 26
years um it's how he puts up with me
when i feel
my like whatever emotion rise i
immediately raise my voice
it's how i assert power in the
relationship
and i am so committed lewis
to breaking that pattern wow and being a
more fun person to be around and a
kinder person to be around this is a
very important first piece of advice by
the way is that a lot of times we start
to feel the weight of the overwhelm but
we don't get out of our heads and if you
spend too much time thinking about all
the stuff that's going on
and you don't go through the process of
breaking it down
and figuring out what actually is
important to you and prioritizing what
you're going to do about it you're just
going to continue to feel heavier and
heavier and heavier it's more and more
sunk i mean it's it's a very very
difficult thing to feel having a
breakdown is one of the biggest things
on the planet because what you get is
you get a break from your own [__]
and you can look
objectively at where you are and for the
first time
look ahead and say well what do i want
to go create and nine times out of ten
if you're discouraged right now if
you've got financial devastation if
you've if you're facing something that
is making this moment in time as hard
for you as life was for lewis and i in
2008 during the last recession
i beg you
ask yourself honestly if what you had is
actually what you wanted
the thing that you just lost that that
job that you bitched about all the time
a relationship that was bad to you yeah
yes or the friends you can't hang out
with because it's convenient and you
can't you're in court like actually ask
yourself if this is what you wanted or
were you just used to it
being used to something
louis i think is the biggest reason why
people don't change
i asked my mother i love my mother i
love my parents i've been married 51
years
which is a feat because they were my mom
was a teen mom but
uh i asked her once if she'd go to a
personal development seminar with me
what'd you say
are you [__] kidding me
why would i want to change at my age wow
i might discover i hate my life
wow
i was like okay i'm just gonna leave
that right there and it's all that
thinking that overthinking that thinking
too big thinking big is about dreams
thinking big is about goals thinking big
is about your heart and your soul and
figuring out what you want then once you
do that and you think big and you see
where you're headed
boom you got to come back and you've got
to go brick by brick to make that vision
stick you've got to go brick by brick to
make the action stick you got to go
brick by brick to lay that pathway
forward and to keep going and let me
tell you something i don't care how busy
you are i don't care how tired you are i
don't care how much there is to do to
make this big dream forward you have
time to lay one brick a day you really
do
you really do and this is the secret
everybody this is the secret to
everything it's to understanding that
there is no timeline to getting your
dreams done
all there is to do is to allow your
heart and soul to dream big
to see the path forward and then to pull
yourself into the moment every day and
have the discipline to be deliberate to
lay one brick on that path that's it and
to keep reminding yourself that
everything that you're learning on the
way as you lie bricks down and you move
forward a little at a time
is helping you build the path and there
will be times that you start to lay
bricks in this direction and you realize
whoa wait a minute i'm going over here
and my dream is over there i guess i
better lay bricks over here and head
back in the direction then you're gonna
go this way that's great because
everything that you learned over here
is going to be exactly what you needed
in order to be
doing what your big dream is and i
always talk about how you have the power
in your life always i know that you may
have your feelings hurt
i know you may
be angry or upset or frustrated i
certainly feel those things all the time
in my life but i want you to understand
that no matter what's going on you
always have the power because you can
choose what you think and what you do
next
you may not be able to control the way
that somebody treated you you may not be
able to control uh the number of
promotions that have passed you by you
may not be able to control whether or
not your boss is a jerk face or not to
you
but you can choose how you respond to
these things and that's where your power
is why do you think that is in human
beings that
you know things are going bad we won't
change
if they're going good we won't change
but it's almost like we need a massive
breakdown near death experience divorce
covid for us to see clearly to start
changing
well there's a really simple answer
patterns
so the thing about all human beings is
that we are pattern
learning machines
and if you feel
stuck or broken i guarantee you while
you feel that way you're not you have a
pattern of behavior or a pattern of
thinking that is broken
and we
need
to be disrupted
because we love our patterns
and even people that i know like i've
heard
even when we're in pain we like pain's
familiar for a lot of people yeah so a
lot of people like you may be listening
to lewis and i talking and you grew up
in a super chaotic household
maybe your parents argued all the time
maybe your dad or mom were in and out
maybe there was a lot of fighting maybe
there was actual abuse i don't know what
was going on but it was chaotic as hell
and so as an adult
you have vowed yourself you are not
going to repeat that pattern
but what ends up happening is because as
a little kid you observed witness
absorbed the pattern of chaos in your
nervous system unless you go about the
intentional work
of breaking the pattern of chaos
you will create it in your own life
because it's what's familiar
you won't understand why do i keep
dating these why do i why do i go to
these bosses that treat me like crap
because you don't know
what it feels like
to be in a relationship with either a
boss or a romantic partner or a roommate
that is consistent because for the first
18 years of your life you lived in an
estate called when's the next shoe gonna
drop right
and so wherever it is in your life that
something is broken there is a pattern
that you don't see yet that is making
you continue to stay in a broken
situation the world doesn't need another
perfect person
the world needs you
and you're trying your best
you're doing what you can and you know i
think it's really important that you cut
yourself a break
and that you stop thinking that you have
to be perfect there are going to be days
where you're an hour late to pick up
your kid and that's okay
there are going to be days when you
can't get to every email and that's okay
there are going to be days where you
feel so underwater and that's okay
you'll get through it you'll figure it
out and you've got to understand that
it's not about being perfect
it's about just being you and that means
that you got to be willing to start
before you're ready you got to be
willing to
do what i do every damn day which is
show up in my rollers or start a live
stream and disconnect myself or start it
and be talking and not even know that
i'm broadcasting
you've got to do that version in your
life or you're not going to get ahead
period i've looked into the research
there's only one
habit and skill just one
that has a direct impact on how much
money you make
a direct impact on whether or not you
get the promotion and the influence and
the cash
money that you deserve and do you know
what that is
any ideas
the one skill
the one habit
the one thing that has a meaningful
behavior change that impacts
what you get
it's your visibility you see you don't
get credit you don't get paid for and
you don't get graded on the things that
people can't see
in order for you to get what you deserve
you have to start being deliberate about
your visibility behavior that you've got
to start learning to do whether you're
shy
whether you're introverted whether
english is your second language it
doesn't matter you've got to learn how
to speak up you've got to learn how to
share your ideas you've got to learn how
to talk about your business you've got
to learn to talk about your dreams and
your goals and i know for many of you
that is one of the most terrifying
things in the world you hate being the
center of attention the idea of speaking
in a meeting at work and risking
sounding like you don't know what you're
talking about is really scary the idea
of asking for feedback from your boss or
asking for a raise really scary the idea
of going in and talking your professor
about adjusting your grade really scary
the idea of raising your hand i get it i
read your emails i see the comments but
you've got to understand that this is
the number one skill that you need
in order to increase your visibility
wherever it is that you need to increase
your visibility instead of doing what so
many of us do when we're broken up with
and we go i'm a loser i'm unlovable i'm
not good enough
what i want you to do instead is i want
you to put that opinion and judgment on
the relationship itself
that relationship that's over wasn't
good enough
wasn't worthy and wasn't the right fit
for love for you
do not take that on as an internal
judgment of yourself
make sure that when you're judging it
you're judging the relationship and how
it wasn't a good fit for you
you my friend are whole you my friend
are perfect how you are and yeah you may
have to change yeah yeah there's things
that you can do better now that you know
better yes there's baggage you got to
deal with but there's nothing wrong with
you there's just patterns that you need
to deal with if you're not facing a
breakup personally in your romantic life
you still want to pay attention because
somebody that you care about might be
and this is advice that you can give to
them also breakups uh
happen in your career
you might be breaking up with a work
situation you might be breaking up with
a friend i know a lot of us are working
hard to draw boundaries and to surround
ourselves with more positive people and
we get questions every day about how you
do that and so breaking up with friends
can be just as traumatic as breaking up
with somebody that is a romantic partner
i have three steps to getting over a
breakup that i'm going to explain in a
minute but first i want to under i want
to explain some research to you to help
you put what you're feeling into context
because what you're going through when
you break up with somebody or you're
broken up with
is you literally
go through withdrawal
i'm not kidding and yeah i'm using the
word withdrawal
where else do you hear the word
withdrawal you hear the word withdrawal
when you hear about people withdrawing
from a drug and that's a lot uh similar
to what you're going through in fact
there was a study done by
lucy brown who found that like drug
abuse romantic love begins with that
euphoric feeling
it's a high right
and when the drug leaves your body or
the romance leaves your life what are
you left with you're left with the
withdrawal which is a craving for it
validate number one
breakfast breakups are painful but they
don't need to lead you broken so i want
you to validate where you're at it's
great that you're asking the question
you got to have a little bit of
compassion for yourself you got to
understand that you're going to be sad
for a while but please don't pour
gasoline on the sadness fire please
please please don't be staring at photos
of your ex please don't be
putting his or her social media face
right in front of your face it's gonna
make it worse but definitely validate
the sadness because you're going through
a major change and it might not be a
change that you wanted number two
separate this is the most important part
because the other thing that i don't
think any of us realize is that when you
get broken up with or you break up with
somebody
you don't realize how much of your daily
routine and the habits that you have and
the way that you go about your day was
tied to the person that you're no longer
with and so what you're not only dealing
with is not only missing the person but
your whole
life schedule
may have just been thrown off maybe you
two went to the same gym in the morning
maybe you got a text in the morning from
this person maybe you liked your little
facetime call at work maybe
your friend group became their friend
group and now all of a sudden that
you're broken up because you hung out
with their friends all the time you
don't have that social life anymore and
so it is so important for you to
recognize that you're not only facing
the person being gone but the habits
that marked your day and the other
people that maybe you hung out with and
the things that you did with your time
and the music that you listened to and
the food that you ate that those might
have all been dictated by the person you
were with and those are changing too so
it's important for you to separate your
self i think a lot of women in
particular when we get into a
relationship we tend to lose ourselves
we tend to morph into the person that
we're dating i used to do that all the
time
and so
now we get to the third part
as you start to think about separating
right so you're validating where you're
at you're separating from this person we
need to get to the third part which is
celebrating you
now that you're broken up you have an
opportunity you have an opportunity to
rediscover yourself because i guarantee
you you lost a bit of yourself in that
relationship and so as you think about
the way that the structure of your day
is changed what can you proactively
insert that is a celebration of the
things that you stopped doing
what have you been keeping yourself from
doing because you were in this
relationship that would celebrate you
who are the friends or family members or
colleagues that really lift you up and
how can you find more time to hang out
with them this is a time to celebrate a
moment when you get to rediscover you
you'll get the day
where you celebrate and that was
yesterday
and
you'll have that moment where you cannot
believe that you actually got into the
school that you wanted or you got the
job that you wanted or you
found the person that that really
complements you finally or that you got
the raise that you wanted or you built
the house that you've always dreamt of
and then a funny thing happens after you
actually achieve the dream
after you celebrate
life goes right back to the way that it
was
and for me what i'm present to is not
the fact that
this talk show's actually happening it's
i'm focused on all the work that i now
need to do
in order to do
the talk show as powerfully as i can and
i think
that
the point that i'm trying to make about
the fact that yeah you can achieve all
the things that you're going for but
i've even noticed already in just 24
hours like that the crazy rise in
emotion and excitement has already been
replaced with things are back to normal
that is exactly what psychologists talk
about when it comes to happiness because
happiness is not about achieving things
it's not about getting the result it's
about
how you
pursue the things
that you enjoy and why you're pursuing
them and so
the key to life and i'm seeing it happen
in my own life is not actually checking
the boxes and getting all those things
that you dream about
it's
how you go about living your life as
you're pursuing them because if i were
just gonna like boop check the box and
now i'm done biggest goal of my life to
have a daytime talk show just achieve
that
what do i have to look forward to
nothing if you've already achieved it
which is why it's so important for you
to
understand that the real meaning of
happiness is about how you show up every
day yes you should have big goals yes
you should have big dreams yes yes yes
and yes you should pursue them
don't ever think that quote making your
dreams come true is what actually makes
you happy because what actually makes
you happy is having those big dreams and
waking up every morning
and doing a little something to push
yourself to make them happen it's about
the pursuit we live in the most amazing
moment in time
so that thing that you have up here
whatever it may be you want to use
healthy eating to cure your diabetes you
want to figure out how to take care of
the elders and start a new hospice
center you want to move to africa and
build a school guess what you could walk
into a bookstore right now
and buy at least 10 books written by
credentialed experts on how the hell you
do it
you could google it and you could
probably find at least i don't know
a thousand blogs
documenting the step by step by step
transformation that somebody else is
already doing
you can find anybody online and cyber
stalk them
you can just walk in their footsteps and
let that you know just use the science
of drafting follow what everyone else
has done because somebody else is
already doing it
so why don't you have what you want
when you have all the information that
you need you have the contacts that you
need there are probably free tools
online that allow you to start a
business or join a group or do whatever
the heck you want
it all comes down to one word
shut the front door you know what i'm
talking about
the f-bomb it's everywhere
you hear it all the time and i i
honestly don't understand what the
appeal is of the word i mean you don't
sound smart when you say it
and it's really not expressing how you
really feel
it's sort of a cheap
you know shot to take and of course you
know i'm talking about the word
fine
how you doing i'm fine
oh really you are
dragging around those extra 40 pounds
you're fine
feeling like roommates with your spouse
and you're fine you haven't had sex in
four months you're fine
really
i don't think so
but see here's the deal with saying that
you're fine
it's actually genius
because if you're fine
you don't have to do anything about
it but when you think about this word
fine
it just makes me so angry i mean here we
are at a conference about being alive
and you're going to describe the
experience of being alive as fine
what a flimsy and feeble word
if you're crappy say you're crappy if
you're amazing say you're amazing
tell the truth
and this not only goes for the social
construct oh i don't want to burden you
with the fact that i hate my life or you
know hey i'm amazing but that would make
you feel terrible
the bigger issue
the bigger issue with fine is that you
say it to yourself
that thing that you want i guarantee you
you've convinced yourself that you're
fine
not having it
that's why you're not pushing yourself
it's the areas in your life where you've
given up where you've said oh i'm fine
my mom's never gonna change so i just
can't have that conversation
i'm fine you know we got to wait until
the kids graduate before we get divorced
so we'll just sleep in separate bedrooms
i'm fine i lost my job i can barely pay
my bills but
whatever it's hard to get a job
and you know one of the reasons why
this word also just annoys me so much
is scientists
have calculated
oh yeah i'm coming down scientists have
calculated
the odds
of you
being born
that's right they've crunched the
numbers i see you up there
they have crunched the numbers on you
yeah i know you guys standing up you
want to sit down for this
they've crunched the numbers on you
being born
and they took into account
all
of the wars and the natural disasters
and the dinosaurs and everything else
and do you realize
that the odds
the odds of you yeah right here put your
computer away stand up for me doug
so the odds of doug here turn around say
hi to everybody the odds yeah of doug
doug being born
at the moment in time he was born
to the parents you were born to with the
dna structure that you have
a hundred or no one and four hundred
trillion
isn't that amazing i'm so lucky
yes
you're not fine you're fantastic
you have life-changing ideas for a
reason and it's not the torture yourself
thank you
thank you doug
you know christine was right when she
said all of you could be on stage
because all of you we're all in this
category
one and four hundred trillion
all day long you have ideas that could
change your life that could change the
world that could change the way that you
feel
and what do you do with them
nothing
hopefully it won't moon you
you didn't pay for that so let's talk
about starbucks starbucks in 2008
um very interesting thing happened and
many of you if you were in the financial
services market then probably know this
that their net income decreased by about
28 that year and at the time they had
16 000 stores in 44 countries and they
had gone through this massive explosive
growth
segment in terms of going from going
public in i think it was like 1992 they
only had 125 stores and now here we are
2008 they've got 16 000. so what ends up
happening is howard schultz who is the
chairman of the board comes back in as
the ceo very complex situation right
you've got operations in 44 countries
you've got massive reduction in terms of
the profits that you have you've got the
stock market and wall street screaming
at you you've got customers that are
going to dunkin donuts because there's a
recession that's hitting so what do you
do well he was very clear again back to
the two rules what do i stand for
like what is it uh what is what am i
doing
and what do i want the outcome to be
so he was very clear that what he stood
for as a leader and what starbucks
should stand for is the starbucks
experience he wanted to go back to the
beginning and
reintroduce people to the romance of
having a cup of coffee because you know
that's how starbucks launched in the
beginning that he was traveling and was
over in italy and was like god why don't
we have places like these great stops to
have a little cup of coffee over in the
united states boom starbuck's an idea
it's born it's launched so he decides
he's going to do whatever he can to get
the romance of having a cup of coffee
back in life in any situation whether
you're talking about growing your
company growing your bank account
getting in a relationship getting out of
a relationship getting something done at
the school system that your kids are
going to on behalf of your kids whatever
it is that you're up to in life this is
the only question that you need to ask
yourself what is it that i want
because the truth of the matter is if
you can answer that you can have it what
about when someone can't realize or
identify their own negative feelings
someone that has been conditioned to
live in negative feelings and believes
that that's normal this question comes
from baso anna dinagada
um it is your normal you're right
it's a really um
first of all i'm sorry that that's been
your experience of life because that
really stinks and it doesn't have to be
that way
but here here's where i want you to go
what's interesting about what you said
is the fact that these feelings are
normal okay normal just means you're
used to them
but you don't have to live with them
so even though you're so used to these
negative feelings and these feelings of
doubt
you still don't like them
you still have the ability to stop that
so i want you to think of a moment in
time when you were really happy like it
could be a memory from being little it
could be something that you dream of
doing and i want you to come up with
something really specific about that
moment okay like think about what you're
wearing or think about the the the blue
sky that is going to be what i call your
anchor thought
every time from this moment forward
that you wake up or you find yourself
drifting to those normal feelings of i'm
a loser
i'm worthless
i'm never going to find love
they may be things that you're used to
thinking
but that doesn't that doesn't matter
because you can change them
the second that you
feel that you've drifted over into that
thought and i keep coming over here
because when you start using the rule
you're gonna start to literally feel
which part of your mind you're using the
worries kind of happen here
i want you to five four three two one
and then i want you to insert this
vision of yourself this vision of
yourself where you felt really good
and if you can't think of one invent one
how would you feel if you were in love
how would you feel if you loved yourself
how would you feel if you did that thing
that you're scared of that you keep
talking yourself out of that's your
anchor thought now when you first start
using the rule particularly when you're
breaking a habit
a habit of thinking negative thoughts
when you first start doing it you may
need to use the five second rule 73
times in one day that's okay
i had to do it like that when i was
first using the rule to cure myself of
anxiety
when i would start to worry about
anything i'd start to worry about you
know my kids or i'd start to worry about
money and i'd feel my thoughts drift and
then i'd start to feel my heart race i
would stabilize my thoughts five four
three two one i've activate my
prefrontal cortex lower the the worries
you know on the other side and then i
would start to think
about something that actually made me
feel really calm or excited
that is the battle of your mind
and you know the other thing about
normal that i just want to say is that
the reason why
it feels normal to doubt yourself
and to have low self-worth
is because you've thought this so long
it's become a pattern just like chewing
your nails becomes a pattern of behavior
that you don't think about well the cool
thing is is that based on science you
can actually change any pattern even a
thinking one
so use the five second rule
every single time you catch yourself
thinking the nasty stuff
and then activate your prefrontal cortex
and
force yourself to think something
positive so if it were easy to get what
you wanted in life google would have
already figured out an app you would
just type in okay i'm a student and i
want to go from being a student to being
successful and google would tell you go
to college then you get your masters
then you land this killer job and then
you put in a bunch of face time while
you're checking facebook
then you get promoted to manager and
then you realize managing people kind of
stinks and then you keep climbing the
corporate ladder and then you start to
wonder well how did i end up here
and then you went is this what success
looks like you're like no i'm going to
go to jay hilburn that's what success
looks like
um
so keep this in mind if there's
something that you want like seven
people or a trip to africa or you're
going to make it to mexico and the pink
shirt i'm looking at you again sir
i'm watching you um
and rooting for you uh keep in mind this
here you are
this is what you want i spent a lot of
time on lacrosse fields although they
don't really look like this
you tend to think that what you want you
just march right towards it but if in
sports you march right towards the goal
what happens the defenders come in and
what the defenders are is it's your
brain saying ain't gonna happen so the
second you start moving toward that
thing you want be ready you're gonna
tell yourself you don't feel like it
you're gonna have to force yourself it's
happening there's no way to get around
it so what you're gonna have to do is
you're gonna basically get bounced
around a lot
all over the place
and they're going to be a lot of times
that you feel like this was a really
dumb idea to start this business
because it's going to get hard
and i want to remind you about something
unlike a sports field where there's an
in and out of bounds the great thing
about life is there actually aren't any
and it's usually in those moments where
you feel like you can't do it that
you're closer than ever to having
everything that you wanted
and i wanted to show you this so that
you keep it in mind because i think a
lot of times when you look back it's the
darkest moments where you realize holy
cow that's what projected me forward
every single morning monday through
fridays at 9 00 a.m i host a live call
in radio show on sirius satellite radio
it's called make it happen with mel
robbins and the thing that's been so
crazy about that show is
every single person that calls me on
that show
they call in because they're feeling
stuck in their lives and they're
resigned about their ability to change
their lives and i'm not talking about
people that are nuts i'm talking about
successful people like you and me that
just somehow got stuck in their lives
and i'm not talking about people that
are looking for cheesy self-help i'm
talking about people that really want to
figure out how to move themselves
forward and you know i find that so many
of us think that our dreams are
unreachable or unrealistic and it's just
so sad i mean people think that their
dreams disappear and if that's what you
think congratulations you're officially
stuck
and the truth is that our dreams are
always there and they don't ever give up
on us
we give up on them
but here's the secret
if you just force yourself and i mean
force because i know damn well none of
you want to do anything about this and i
also know you're sitting there like yeah
the self-help crap this isn't for me but
if you just force yourself to take a
couple small steps there's always a
surprise
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel just for it go check
it out the link is right there next to
me continue to believe and i'll see you
there